a Rhode Island School official under
investigation for apparently trying to
raise money
to clear a illegal student's debt to a
cartel
the Mount Pleasant assistant principal
writing to staffers quote we have a
student who came to America with coyote
which is a group that helps people our
student needs our urgent support to
raise another two thousand dollars
the Border crisis a top priority for
Republicans as new house Judiciary
Committee chair Jim Jordan schedules his
very first hearing on the topic for this
week Congress and Daryl Isis sits on
that committee and joins us now
Congressman thanks for being here first
of all
it's staggering that a school official
would send an email like this thinking
that paying a cartel is a good thing and
it makes you wonder how how many
students across America might be saddled
with the same situation they they have
to pay back effectively indentured
servitude to the cartels so which
traffic them here illegally
well we know that we have more than a
million so-called getaways this year so
uh the fact is that there are lots and
lots and lots some of them are underage
women working in in the sex trade that's
just a reality that we deal with every
day but it's the part the committee will
be looking not just at the side effects
and and the those who are here that got
around the system but we're going to be
looking specifically at failure to
comply with the intent of the law and
the impact it's having around the
country when you say failure to comply
with the intent of the law you mean a
rampant exploitation of Asylum and this
idea that everyone's a migrant right as
opposed to an illegal breaking the law
well exactly and you know it's uh it
would be like saying well you know we're
going to we're not going to prosecute
anyone for any any drug crime or we're
not going to prosecute anyone for
assault uh and what we're going to do
instead is we're going to schedule that
in the future we're going to have a
trial and then we're going to release
them and never have the trial that's
effectively what's going on Americans
understand that we're not even
processing a tenth of the people that
are being allowed in per year so every
year that goes by there will be Millions
more people in the backlog by intent and
those people will become American is
clearly what this Administration wants
to do it's unfair to those individuals
if someday they've become very American
uh and then they're sent home because
America cannot or will not tolerate if
you will those who got in ahead of those
who waited in line because their First
Act was an illegal one when they came to
this country real quick just for my own
curiosity I don't normally associate the
border with the Judiciary Committee so
it's great to see it a top priority but
how did it land there it's the odd thing
is having been the chairman of oversight
you know we often look at oversight
because it can go anywhere and
investigate anything but when it comes
to actually changing these laws or
changing the enforcement of these laws
it falls squarely on Judiciary uh the
Judiciary immigration uh is exclusive to
uh to that committee the laws that the
president are is not Faithfully
upholding in our opinion at least in my
opinion uh were created in this
committee uh not just a while ago but
decades ago before Henry Hyde was a
senior member uh and that's what's sad
is that the law hasn't changed the
president's willingness to reinterpret
it in a way that's never been this broad
uh is happening happening the more you
know all right well I I'm glad this is
the top issue because it's it should be
front and center the media except for us
is ignoring it but you guys are not
Congressman thank you so much thank you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis